[Music]
game number two of this four game series
to open the 2020 season today it is
lance mccullers going to the mount for
the first time since 2018.
kyle's secret bats here in the first
inning
[Music]
outstanding job of getting to it in
right center field by springer and then
knowing that correa was the gun that he
has able to turn and
were able to hold up evan white at third
base
this might just be a little bit of the
coming of the nerves here's austin nolan
with one out here in the first there's
the ground ball
there's one over the first of the double
play
let's mccullars
gets out of a jam
jeff bloom called it just takes one get
that ground ball use that all-star
defense behind you dangerous laid off
man here's the pitch swung on popped up
shallow down the first base side over
toward the seat seven white reaches over
and he makes the catch
holy smokes what a grab by evan white
got to the railing leaned over and had
just enough room to make the catcher
there's one out for the astros here in
the bottom of the first inning you're
going to love his glove blocking a
single has two many board for the astros
bramley's got it right where he wants it
line drive over the glove and that will
score out two days
michael brantley with an rbi single in
the right field and the astros take a
one-nothing lead the ball was stunned
but both runners were off getting enough
on it that [ __ ] long just off the
typical left rbi to go here in the
fourth inning now lewis leads it up
swinging a bit second strike out of the
game for last mccullers
here
good pitch in under the hands and he
gets bogo back for his third strikeout
the second of the inning really looking
for his first hit of the season
that would crank the left and way out of
here julie guriel with his first hit of
the season and it leaves the yard in a
big way and the astros are on top two to
[Music]
but rick down nothing line
tucker digging for second correa will
score
and he's in there and the astros extend
the lead
kyle tucker at that one just inside that
right field line
and he's got himself an rbi double his
first hit of the season martinez have
good swings and he's at that so far has
two runners in scoring position here
with one out in the fourth that one hit
left field
decor is not going to get to that one
off the base of the wall two runs will
score and the astros extend their lead
once again to five to nothing martine
maldonado a two-run
single ball was hit extremely well d
gord didn't play it perfectly off the
wall but did enough to keep paulden on
first base astros with a five-nothing
lead over seattle as we start the fifth
inning
that one hit well
deep to center field springer back and
springer off the wall
couldn't hold on they will hold him up
at third base but jp crawford
with the triple and a great effort by
george springer reddick out there seeing
if he's all right it's good to see him
bounce up he's an incredible athlete
throws with a 6-1 lead over seattle kyle
lewis
back out to right field a lot of carry
back and gone
[Music]
george springer with his first hit of
the season
and he'll take the tour and the astros
lead at seven to two set him up
that you did and he knocked him down
that's the george we're used to seeing
change up up in the zone recognized and
absolutely pummeled
he's a lot of fun to watch when he gets
into that baseball and gets it hard
tonight
by a score of seven to two that'll bring
up left
[Music]
[Music]
this should do it and there's your ball
game
after an 8-2 win to start the season the
astros take the first two of this
four-game series
as they knock off
the seattle mariners by a score of 7-2
and that is now 15 straight wins over
the seattle mariners